der Traum vom Eigenheim wird Ihnen
präsentiert von renovero für jedes
Projekt Handwerker einfach online finden
auf
[Applaus]
[Musik]
renovero.ch Ziel
D ich find das gemeinschaftliche
meiz mir m immer alles auf Tisch legen
und zwar
STI Ding so ich bin
nichttiegen Metall und wir sind jetztund
1,5 Millionen Eigenmittel wir sind elich
drüber dem was
[Applaus]
manit
momi me
Idee W auch machen
überlegt das mal wir machen das so und
so und dann W das mehr Generationen Haus
machen und du Mö ich ne in ein altershim
oder irgendwie wenn irgend
[Musik]
mir dir das ernst wirk mit
mir ja D nicht
[Musik]
fren ja das irend wegbringen das ganze
zü vier Generationen ein Ziel aus diesem
alten rstall möchten Sie Ihr Zuse bauen
drei Wohnungen auf drei Etagen sind
geplant in der Mitte wird Großmutter Rut
wohnen im Erdgeschoss ihre Tochter
ebenfalls
Rut und die andere Tochter Susanna wird
mit ihrem Mann Pat in den Dachstock
einziehen Enkel philip ist vor kurzem
ins Nebenhaus
eingezogen zusammen mit seiner Frau
Jenny die beiden werden in Kürze zum
ersten Mal Eltern
aufmachen das lang sch
gut ja irgendein Kollege hat mal gesagt
was du züglich mit der Schwiegermutter
zammen habacht aber natürlich auf dem
auf dem WAG der Prozess wo wir mit dem
projektesetzt ganz am Anfang sind das
schon überleg nicht nur we der
Schwiegermutter der schwger generell
kann das funktionieren wird
funktionieren das sind schon überlegige
wo man natürlich
gemacht
seit einem halben Jahr wohnen Philip und
Jenny im
Nebenhaus und dann
dem neben ihrem ersten Kind haben die
beiden 27jährigen noch ein anderes
Projekt sie möchten auf dem Grundstück
einen Pferdestall bauen aber Dasing
so
ab schaff alles mit dem Stall und das
Bauprojekt und Kind und ist ja mega
schön wenn man die ressourc mit wo
groß natürlich sicher Verand
[Musik]
zum so K
mit
[Musik]
hallo einmal pro Woche treffen sich
allei und
zuritung Zukunft irgendwann Pension
vielleicht noch weg ist und wo die
Diskussion da die
schnapsideeemt derich Ideen und träum
Fantasie ich ma mich selbstig
dertherapie und drum das ein ein großer
trumon mir zum mir die ST oder muss das
so
groß aber
diskutiert ier das Wind ob off mit Ding
Staub und weiß ich was für
dre mir m immer alles auf der Tisch
legen und zwar fr kN das man einfach das
minand
diskutiert wie kann ein Zusammenleben
gelingen mit so vielen Menschen mit so
unterschiedlichen Bedürfnissen und
finanziellen
Mittel
wir hab jetzt noch
Eigenkapital bis Z ges Punkt wir haben
ja noch die zwei Hüer ihres h Verkauf
und wir hab Millionen wo jetzt S
zammenbringen und und drum ist es
interessant W man Verkauf große Teil du
hast das Hus kauft V 50 Jahr für für
wenig das Projekt kostetgesamt
3,5lionenen fast vier Wohneinheiten plus
den neuen
Pferdestall jede Person bringt
unterschiedlich viel Eigenkapital mit
aber besitzen werden alle gleich viel
und haben auch das gleiche
[Musik]
Mitspracherecht pfeer
hat
t nach Z Jahren Planung der
Baustart eine Architektin gibt es nicht
eine Baufirma realisiert den kompletten
Bau die Auflagen des Kanton turgaus sind
streng der Charakter der Scheune darf
nicht verändert
werden fin einfach lässig dass ich das
überhaupt noch mit mache
ja die Familie möchte beim Bauen mit
anpacken
Balkon mit hol
wie zu teilardine wo man
und immer Bürste Fase und Bürste und das
machen
nochw
dme sind v mitcha
und am Schluss
bestehen das bewusstach zum finden dann
haben wir erhofft
dass
undagt W unterstütz dann
dann
und und ihre Schwester Rut wollten schon
vor Jahrzehnten gemeinsam ein
Hausprojekt realisieren damals waren sie
noch mit anderen Männern liiert jetzt
wollen sie ihren Traum realisieren
zusammen im Grünen wohnen und auch
Arbeiten in ihrer eigenen
akupressurpraxis das mir such ich kan
ger ich zum Hus und einfach F
laufen das für mich Freiheit
ja ja Problem ist einfach W autahren ja
W halt irgend ist
aber Plan schon mal
so einfach einmal in der
wocheen und einfach
nicht zur nächsten Einkaufsmöglichkeit
ist es zu Fuß eine halbe Stunde zur
nächsten Post eine
Stunde auch das Projekt nebenan nimmt
Form an
der kleine L ist
daol wirklich
charak weiß sch
und wenn Hunger dann möchte
jetzt in den kommenden Monaten wird Tag
für Tag emsig an ihrem Traum gearbeitet
sämtliche Wände werden ersetzt und die
Balken der drei Etagen
montiert
[Musik]
sto sind fix gesetzt
ja
schön
ja jedes Wochenende macht die Familie
arbeiten die sonst Lehrlinge
erledigen irg Vogel wo da in verandt ist
so wie viicht da zwischen de Metall und
dem Holz l mal muss
SP Philip hat eine enge Bindung zu
seiner
Herkunftsfamilie Tür an Tür mit ihnen zu
leben für ihn kein Problem noch sind
alle gesundheitlich fit doch wie wird es
in Zukunft sein wenn Großmutter Mutter
Tante und Onkel einmal nicht mehr so
selbstständig
sind glaub so WN in der Familie bist du
bist du sowieso dafinand WN wenn man
jetzt
oder nicht
weiß 15 Jahre und me WN man mit der
Angst das Projekt in wä so hey was
passiert wenn W zwei sterb W WN Z
krank dann hätte man das GL so der könen
machen das ganze
Projekt Philip möchte für seine Familie
da sein auch für seinen angeheirateten
Onkel Pat sie sch da sie sind Biss
wierp aber besser W kurz ber so
Rolle
Fam und m zwei Frau im
H drum
hat bin
irgend Vaterersatz göt
Ersatz unkle irgendwie und
ja und von dem her ist es irgendwie
völlig natürlich dass miram gehören um
mögliche Erbstreitigkeiten zu verhindern
wird auch Philips Schwester
testamentarisch gleichberechtigt wie
Philip in dieses Projekt
einbezogen
find einfach hilft
einfach Rut Senior steht mit 77 Jahren
noch einmal vor einem neuen
Lebensabschnitt mit gemischten
Gefühlen einfach
ja die
H en und das
ist WSS das ist jetzt einfach so
[Musik]
ja fast jedes Wochenende arbeitet die
Familie auf der Baustelle Susanne und P
können es kaum erwarten hier
einzuziehen was ich mir hoffe ist die
Ruhe W ich da wir finde und auch die
Kompaktheit wonig ist groß aber sie ist
auf einem Stock und ich habe n D Stück
und das ist eiglich das wo wo wo ich
mich du freue alles gut
sch der
Fuß
Fuß immer danke für den
Kaffee DAH hin entst der
rotstall ja genau so breit wird ca und
dann so lang ich glaube wenn Sie den da
sind dann wird der Bezug auch noch ganz
anders jetzt sind einfach ja die R macht
viel Mist und so und wie machen man denn
das und ich glaub es ist alles so
so und dann komm mE gut nicht alle
teilen den Traum dass hier auch Pferde
leben sollen den dufte Tiere haben sie
gerade erst mit einer
Spezialimprägnierung aus dem Holz
verbandt stinkt die
oder ja schmeck gar nicht ich
eigentlichmer le nicht D und ich bin
immer im R von der SCH h m Gehör dann
die dass ich stinke
also ich bin nicht Fan das ist die gen
sa aber
ich es muss J s wissen aber ich ich
nicht mit
[Musik]
dem
Rickenbach Sulz in der Nähe von
Wintertour da komm wsen
über ich bin jetzt 46 Jahre
de immer noch ist einf
Rut inzwischen Urgroßmutter hat Zweifel
ob es richtig war den Schritt zu
wagenfach
weg und das das ist das gut sie mir
versprochen sie wür mich dann aber ist
gich
nichtich einfach abhauen wenn ich
w ja ist einfach
so das da ich schlaf immer oder es
gesen das du jetzt
weg komm neu
über alles ganz Schlafzimmer wird
neu in diesem Haus hat sie ihre Kinder
groß gezogen zusammen mit ihrem Mann
Jakob seit seinem Tod vor 5 Jahren
belastete sie das Haus samt großem
Garten mehr und
[Musik]
mehr
dass man immer alles muss selber
entscheiden und das sch schon nicht so
einfach 20
bin kom dannben NOZ macht einfach nicht
me so R einfach gemkt dass das irgendis
Mus
andterchwerde
seit einem halben Jahr wird auf der
Baustelle Tag für Tag gearbeitet heute
geht es um ein wichtiges Element des
Hauses den Lift dieser ist für sie nicht
nur essentiell im Alter auch für die
zukünftige Praxis von Susanne und
Rut also wirklich
standardusfü hat z.B die Türe auch
automatisiert mit dem kan der PR nach
wir
müsen nain gut aber dann wä
wahrscheinlich die Option so wie sie im
Angebot ist mit der standardusfü ich GLB
auch in mit der Rückwand das spielt doch
nicht so eine Rolle oder das ist das ist
GLB das macht Sinn
oder trägt die Verantwortung für die
Finanzen der 56jährige hat schon einmal
gebaut er verfügt über die nötige
Erfahrung
RIS inemacht also dass man DIN
schonat aber sch natürlich
müs nicht
also nicht unbedingt aber ist
jetzt es g Hal nicht
anders die Familie ist im engen
Austausch mit der
holzbaufir fortgeschritten ist und
welche Arbeiten sie selbst erledigen
können
mus Weg
sind wir sind wir sind am Lernen genau
Qualitätskontrolle sag man die sind
gutortiert schon viel schlimmere Sache
gesehen also ja und mit pleck und schöne
ist DAO Kundschaft macht da gefallt i
selber auch immer Sie sind viel
schnellerfeden
so
sicher natürlich aber schneller die sind
nehmen die noch aber wenn man sie selber
glug
B es braucht einfach wahnsinnig viel zit
al dan SMer alle im Moment
sehft
ke einfach auch
intensiv aber schönh schön aber sie ist
sehr sehr streng ich hoffe dass S irwann
die ste steh D
dann parallel zu ihrem Einsatz hier sind
Sie
berufstätig Rut Junior und Susanna als
akupressurtherapeutin als Leiter
innendienst jenny ist Sozialpädagogin
und
Reittherapeutin während Philip in der
itbranche
arbeitet seit knapp einem Jahr lebt er
mit seiner Familie im Nebenhaus umgeben
von Natur die Fahrt nach Wintertour
seiner alten Heimat dauert 30 Minuten
mit dem
Auto das ist da halb wo ich den für mich
Bit oder für müs kaufen D abgesch sind
und das ist das ist schon wöigs
bedürftig also nimmt für alles Auto
Kollege sind sich zum zum Z fahre das
ist jetzt jetztis wo eh Minuspunkt ist
dem Objekt ja nicht in kau für für alles
andere schöne wo man dafür
darf in Zürich suchen Sie nach passenden
Küchen wenn Sie sich einig sind und alle
die gleiche wählen wird es günstiger s
da mal
t du musst dich auch wohl fühlen dann
mit dem neumodischen Züg reden von 600
Kubik
schön ich das
probieren ich das Gefühl dass blöde
knöpf elegant mit touchreen aber ich
find jetzt nicht schlimm das lös das
Gefühl das ist n gem modern nicht
ja oder also ja im Katalog W ich i mit
sie alleise hinterle
was
wasostet ich hat gern W so LAF wenn ich
das wett und ich tu
halt dann sag immer gut aber ich sag
halt D W ich will
und gibt Diskussionen oder
Heß mal brems len oder das ist so ja
stromt sch all da wir K in dem Bereich
ja das ist natürlich dain dann sch
schräg ich Straß knapp nachher g sch das
Gen wir sind
da wie jeden Dienstag treffen sie sich
zur
Baubesprechung
ja sindtiegen wei Metall und natürlich
und das sind alle ist wie immer alle die
Hersteller sind natür den
sort auch mit Material W hol
oder Komis ich Kön Hufen optimieren WN
extravagant die Sachen in die und die K
ein Finger
und du darst es mal halt wirklich viel
selber machen denke ich ja und das gut
ich füre ja burchaltig und L wo man ST
und versuch abschätzen aber es ist schon
schwierig
ja GLB da BU wir den
Zi
W wir so vipitz
abstellen je länger die Bauzeit je mehr
werden die finanziellen Mittel ein Thema
die Familie steht vor vielen
Entscheidungen wo können Sie sparen wo
nicht das wä s ein Standard W macht
nicht ja ich glaube es nicht dass das
das Standard ist aber das wür jetzt das
günstige Variante ma okay wie immer fr
mit überle das
wert oder lang die günstige Variante wie
das empfinde
völligend der günstige Variante
drüber hüpfe ja
stampfe jetzt ist der Platte
draf
jetzt Luft auf der auf ander auf bessere
ein
Unterschied ja ja wir m alles machen was
man Kön zum
möglich aber jetzt muss sagen was es
kostet was
danke informiert die Familie über den
aktuellen Stand der Finanzen ihr wüs
dass ich le führe Mitch der Handwerker
zum einigermaßen Überblick
7,7% und jetzt da dass man dann wirklich
verglich mehrf da die wert sind alle
7,7% höcher ja es ist offensichtlich
Fler sind 7,7% oder und das noch aufch
auf der Betrag ja von hat mir schon
momentgt aber jetzt im Nachhinein
ja wie ist beim Sanitär hab wir ja sch
zock will Fehler kan der
kalkulationiger genau lange re kurz s
sind drüber de was man wir sind jetzt
1,5 Millionen
Eigenmittel und was da no
ft
aber vi bis zu mir ich weiß es nicht
aber das K
nicht zwei Sachen machen überle wo Spar
das schwierig D abwarten bis die
restlich und andere aber da
wirklichinetzen wo haben wir noch
Eigenmittel Kön Schü für
[Musik]
mich ist niemand bereit mehr Geld zu
geben auch R Senior nicht sie hat sich
extra Geld aufgespart um sich neue Möbel
zu kaufen das will sie so
[Musik]
beibehalten in Monaten ist
einzugsterminoh
müssen Sie weitere kostspielige
Entscheidungen
treffen
g bestell
fürtür
und
isolationbau machen
Tür hoff dass das ja n am
Schluss
[Applaus]
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
machen wir gen
ja mit der violette das ist STR und der
heißt
leebesperlen
sie ist in der Nachbarschaft
aufachen ich sie
zweitfunden einfacher für mich zum los
ich weiß DFT und sie das schätzt Herz
geschrieben ja
und Marina zieht mit ihrer Familie hier
ein
und hat und S hat ist das ja hat mir
wirklichst mal g g das wä jetzt me
Traum
[Musik]
schön immer neu ja aber g dan man mal
stillstand ist nicht gut und n da sitz
ich und nicht mach und das ist nicht
gut der Verkauf der Häuser von Rut
senior und von Pat und Susanna ist sehr
gut gelaufen finanziell sind sie nun
besser gestellt als erhofft
ja W der Pandemie ich richtig große
Nachfrag nach
Land wü
und typozin sind auf absolut tüpunkt
also hat sich ganz viel lü die überlegig
machen bisis eig kaufen und von dem
haben wirön profitieren und Hüer
eigentlich Tön verkaufen wie mir das
ursprünglich dankt hab das das hilft
[Musik]
e der Bau steht in der Endphase in zwei
Monaten plant die Familie hier
einzuziehen und zu
arbeiten dafür bereiten Sie sich bei
Susanna zu Hause
vor Susanna Jenny und Rut Junior wollen
das Geschäft gemeinsam Aufziehen der
Name Mut Mensch und Tier dafür entwerfen
Sie ein Logo
was macht das du machst ganz dunkel h
Halt und mit Blätter die heller und der
weiß du gar
nicht
soing genau du bist jetztich sehr
absorbiert mit dem LAN und du das gar
nicht so teil und jetzt h die Z für dich
dass du wieder
entfalten
ja ich glaub dasht Fall noch WN das Logo
nim ob der Schrift
dasig ist zum Glück
[Musik]
ja los los los um rechtzeitig fertig zu
werden legen die Bauarbeiter ext
Schichten ein derfang
nicht lang noch
nichtess
ja
Gott
[Musik]
machen und auch der Pferdestall nimmt
Formen
an rstall von me
Bauarbeit famili
und viel die FR und ressourc technisch W
hol K
verwenden Tage bis zum
Einzug um weitere Kosten zu sparen
helfen Freundinnen bei der
Grundreinigung zuerst wollen diese aber
das neue zu Hause bestaunen
wirklich
schön in der Küche haben Sie sich für P
faoriten entschieden ein Kochfeld mit
Touchscreen hat sich viel
verändert Woch alles
gemachtmer ich weiß
nicht sind
Künstler Januar
vor d Jahren haben sie mit der Planung
angefangen unzähige Stunden investiert
nun stehen sie im fast fertigen Haus ein
emotionaler
[Musik]
Moment ja
genau beim Lift haben Sie sich für die
günstigere Variante
entschieden dann hat so ein
Nottelefon und da ist auch W da drauf
g
stop eine Hebebühne direkt im Schacht
diese fährt langsam
ganz de
vi
irgendwie
J ja und jetzt ein fertig ist und sie
ist so
unglaublich ein Jahr Bauzeit ist vorbei
jetzt können Sie endlich
einziehen
ja da muss ja nicht immer hinder da muss
nur
spielb
wie während im Dachgeschoss noch über
die möbelpositionen diskutiert wird
sieht es eine Etage tiefer bei
Urgroßmutter Rut schon wohnlicher
aus ne Schlafzimmer hab ich mir gekauft
das muss ich Hal dann noch schöner
machen jetzt TR alles
su vor hab das doppelb das hab jetzt
Philip und der J geschenkt das ist jetzt
wirklich ein
Neufang ja da vch unten der
R und
eiglich aber noch Bl stim das ganz genau
aber jetzt halt nicht
mal aber hoffe es wer die
[Musik]
gut Z Monate später ziehen die letzten
Bewohner
ein
ol super
ja so Kusch
bettbe
ja sind mehr weniger entspannt
los
so das finde ich
[Musik]
super
damit geht für Jenny ihr Mädchentraum in
Erfüllung sie ist überzeugt die Bedenken
von GR Rut waren
umsonst
B
so so ein geschafft zum das das W
geschafft die letzte sind jah ja
insgesamt
krass
zu Rig
wer zel
ja D Monate
später jor haben ih akessxis
erö tinnen und Patienten sein bereit den
weiteren Weg auf sich zu
nehmen und Jenny hat mit der
Reittherapie
angefangen R Senior genießt die Ruhe
nach dem
Umzugsstress du meistens W so schön W
Morgen und dann sind die Rö auf der weit
das ist schön zum l ja ist jetzt nicht
so schlimm BW
Bienen
einfach Respekt
de
sie sind im Alltag
angekommen die finale Schlussrechnung
hingegen ist noch nicht
gemacht ja mit der Kö so wir sind 300000
ca
überbdget das ist auf Sitte hab GewSt
dass das so wie Bö dr wo man am Anfang
nicht
z. D auf der andereen Seite sind gesse
Sache der Kalkulation einfach Zenig gut
berechnie ist ster
wordde ja ist wir ver nicht ganz so viel
Reserve wir jetzt müssen über Bürer
jetztig Alter m dr
sü ja aber Schluss heute mag trifft sich
die Familie
jor im Erdgeschoss zum gemeinsamen
Mittagessen probieren die Moment
eigentlich zwei bis D Wochen dass man so
wie offizielle offiziell zammensitze
Hand wo Sache besprach wo W off sind wo
wo der Gemeinschaft irendw
vor Themen wo vor j schfangen und und
immer noch nicht abgeschlossen wie mit
Testament wie das genau Reg da bben und
ich danke das Mega wichtig
der falls Konflikt
g ti bringen thematisieren und wier
machen
doch
Spezi was mega cool D halt da sind und
me B so
schön große von phip und freut sich und
ich GLB so Bezug ich überhaupt nicht zu
urßälter und das ist
Geschenk ganze
Stress
Stresslevel g si und man mer gar wie
schön das E ist was alles erreicht haben
zum zum jetzt da ich wünsche mir g B
dass ich
da
ja einfach das
schön ja das
ist
am
Schluss
potenal
mit der Bereitschaft Abstand und Nähe
immer wieder neu zu
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
jtieren der Traum vom Eheim wurde
präsentiert von
Reno Handwerker einfach online finden
auf
renovero.ch